after a long career on his feet Ludovic
shapalan is looking forward to the
option of spending more time like his
customers do
but if the French President gets his way
and raises the retirement age to 64 and
Ludovic will have to spend two more
years behind the bar
during the pandemic the money was found
and the biggest french fortunes grew 189
billion euros I think with this money we
should be able to finance public
pensions a little bit instead of letting
that money go into the pockets of people
who already have so much
foreign
when the government last tried to reform
one of Europe's most generous pension
systems in 2019 there were weeks of
walkouts and protests and then the
pandemic
Emmanuel macron needs a symbolic project
to finally launch his second term what
does he want to do the image of macron
Crisis manager has become so important
the image of reforming macron has
somewhat faded into the background and
from this point of view he desperately
needs this reform if he loses it it will
be the end of Emmanuel macron
opinion polls suggest most people accept
that changes to the pension system are
necessary but around 70 percent say
macron's proposal is unfair
the government says the extra income
from pension contributions will help it
reduce the budget deficit from five
percent to below the EU limit of three
percent by 2027 but rights organizations
have pointed at the Gap in life
expectancy between the poor and the rich
the more you work the less you will have
time to enjoy your pension and actually
for the poorest sometimes you will not
even be able to enjoy your time after
after retiring because you will be
already dead so that's one the second
problem is a problem of employment
with more people staying longer in Job
that means fewer jobs for the Youth
the French on average retire at just
over 62 years old most of their European
neighbors work an additional two or
three years unions say the reforms are
an assault on the welfare system
they've joined forces to lead strikes
involving Transport Services schools
hospitals and refineries what perhaps
matters more to the government because
it doesn't have a majority in Parliament
is what the conservative Republicans do
and they've so far indicated there's a
lot they like about these reforms
Bernard Smith Al Jazeera Paris